là vous venez de vous battre avec le
docteur juifs sauf que maintenant je
vous propose un adversaire d'un autre
calibre qui est pas blanc lui non non
non les verts
vert de rage l'incroyable hulk
l'incroyable juriste
c'est votre mac et où la north et les
muscles c'est vraiment votre mot
à 50/50 plus quand même
si seulement j'étais chemise leur
arracher comme ça ça vous plaît arrêtez
votre cinéma c'est bon je veux plus que
vous présentez vos amis juifs là c'est
fini
allez vous faire soigner
je suis pas fou tout ça fait partie
d'une thérapie très bien pensé qui vient
des pays nordiques et qui est tout
simplement la thérapie par les super
héros voilà donc là c'était l'incroyable
juifs mais ça peut aussi être capitaine
juif j'ai fait spyder juifs ya quelques
années